i'll go sweet i'll go different i'll go
like this rant right now
because one of you [ __ ] might do it
because this is the moment
i'm doing secret content i [ __ ] made
a secret
zoom for you [ __ ] tonight here we are
i don't need to be doing this [ __ ]
i'm dying out here for you guys
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
the way i think about functional content
is that the piece of content
starts the process of you doing
something
and it creates experience it creates
access it creates surprise and delight
uh i remember way back when in the early
days of wine library tv i did something
where
i was doing a wine library tv show but
then i flashed a url
where it might have been on my
chalkboard i don't remember but it sent
you to a url where you did something and
it sent you somewhere else
ultimately it all led to like you
getting like a 30 swag pack and a bunch
of people went through that
kind of easter egg hunt to me that's
what it is
we did a post recently where i post on
instagram there was like a hidden link
you just clicked it you're on a zoom i'm
there it's a it's almost like a key a
trigger
it creates functionality access surprise
and delay things of that nature so
a post that is more than just the
content itself it's a starting point
to something else ultimately what i'm
most excited about is
i think it brings value i i don't when
the promise on the other end is valuable
i think those kind of things trigger and
i think that putting out content
that is for your community the people
that are actually about your community
it's going to cause your community to
pay attention more if there's something
on the other side for them in functional
content i think it's just the way human
psychology works
this is [ __ ] crazy
what i'm just sitting here editing my
podcast took a second
and now i'm talking to garyvee that is
how it works
right you just gotta take the action so
i've just got
one question if
you are in a weird niche right something
that's like
outside of the ordinary seems like
you've got to explain it to people
what is your strategy for making it
mainstream
waiting
i just let everybody hear what i'm about
to say i want to hit everybody to hear
this
when i was yapping about social media
people thought it was dork ass [ __ ]
waiting when you're in a niche it always
becomes
not a niche if it was meant to be
hip-hop was a niche
video games were a niche
everything that it matters tik tok
was [ __ ] on by every guy
18 months ago
you don't even you don't even know how
perfect it is that you said waiting
listen you don't you probably don't even
know what i'm talking about but in human
design my friend you are a projector
their literal strategy as a person is to
wait
to wait you're such a perfect
demonstration i've got a whole blog post
about you a whole youtube video send it
to me i'm so jazzed
i was just you know what's really fun i
love that you're first in this because
talking about innovation like
i literally think the post that i just
posted is gonna be one of the bigger
things i've ever done
i'm not kidding i think this concept of
functional
social media is wild like you post it
but then that triggers
it's the seed of starting something like
i'm so
and this is going to be my call like
definitely my go-to
access i know people want to ask me
questions i know people like interacting
with me i love interacting with you i
love looking at josh
kaufman's face right now we're full
around the world or you know like i love
looking at this tabitha
clark over you know esq like i love this
[ __ ]
and but like the fact that like i can
put out a piece of content and there's
an easter egg in it now
and that's like a portal to where you
can find me for 25 minutes like this is
gonna get fun
it's gonna make social media fun again
because i'm just putting out a seed
right now but
all of y'all like the world's gonna make
it better
but this is just like how cool is this i
post something it's the trigger
to a secret q a session
i love it thank you tiff thank you
i'm gonna go with big shout out
gerald guerrero zac pease oscar estrada
what's good ethan trout i see you
osvaldo martinez what's good sean i see
you sean
via i see you shervin
gerard hines i see you what's good
what's good what's good everyone
all right who's up um arn uh
sorry i can't pronounce it don't worry i
can't probably pronounce every single
person's name that i just said wrong
don't worry andrew vaughn what's good
yeah you're on
hey hi man my god my god okay
i was just finishing writing a song and
i just saw your update
and i'm like okay let's see it's 4am
here in india by the way
i'm i'm impressed with the hustle bro
yeah jesus
like not gonna lie i don't really have a
question for you i just want to give you
a lot of love
because um because um i just posted a
story a few days back i
shut down my personal account and i'm
going ham on being an artist
and one of the last stories on my
personal account was
i just posted all your content that i
had saved
before i deleted my personal account and
i'm like this is for you guys my last
parting gift
before i go ham on being an artist and
my last story was like
your picture and the post was like uh
patience
is an underestimated um
thing right that was your last post that
i posted and i
captioned it that i'm gonna meet this
guy one day not as a friend but as a
fellow human being who just loves this
guy
i appreciate my man i'm so glad we got
to interact just now i wish you nothing
but good just love it
keep going bro keep going we'll talk
soon thank you you're everywhere
you're everywhere trying love you so
much trying love you back
david boyd i see you joining
valentina de la torre great to see you
thank you for being here
orlando matt i can't see you through it
cedric justin
molody matt orlando i squeak derrick
barton i see a lot of
things that i can't see their faces put
your video up
put your video up let me see those faces
amir vincent flory what's good
ig winstonwilliams.dk is in the building
and he's got big [ __ ] guns let's keep
it going dustin i'm ready to talk to
humans
i see you zachary
yo am i speaking to garyvee
you are morgan am i speaking to morgan
with a tremendous haircut right now that
i'm massively jealous of
you are what about the mustache dude
what's your racket the mustache i can
pull off but i can't pull that little
puff up
i can't believe this is so cool i just
dropped by
and all of a sudden i dude i've got
nothing to say i just love your content
i thought i'd drop by and um see if this
was the real deal and as it transpires
it actually is
it is the real deal i really i've been
thinking about this concept
of making social media content matter
more
do more create more and i think this
concept of functional content is real
like
just ima imagine imagine your favorite
hip-hop artist posts a piece of content
but it's not just him or her in the
studio
she's saying come and be with me in the
studio for 20 of you are going to come
in to be in the studio with me here's
the link like
i just think there's more [ __ ] we can do
i think
and i want to test i've always innovated
and i think the post i just posted is an
innovation one that could become
standard social media practice
in five years so i'm excited about it i
think tonight's a special night
and i'm glad all of you are here cool
dude awesome
i love it awesome fantastic idea thanks
for the love
no worries thank you guys compost i see
you bro
thank you for coming through
i'm gonna put on nicolas joaquin i see
you bro
alessandro good if if
anyone that's waiting that doesn't
really todd's iphone i see you big boy
use the raise hand button if you have a
question for gary please
thank you
i know people thought this link was fake
i see you jonathan
i see you bro see the deuces
austin nn is in the building see my guy
oh hello hello nicholas oh my god
i can't believe this i can't believe
that i'm talking to garyvee
i'm from ireland i follow you from years
i always thought oh my gosh if
some someday i could speak to you this
this is incredible
where are you from my friend in korea
i'm from argentina
argentina fantastic how are you i'm
i'm great literally watching your videos
it took me off from a deep place where i
didn't know what to do what to wear to
store
where to go i started making content
in my instagram for
selling some products then i got hired
in a magazine
and now i'm producing content for
for that magazine and it changed my life
completely really this is so
so awesome and i wanted to
ask you uh i'm in the
agrofarming sector yep using content
for a magazine yep
i have two questions my my big interest
is about
healthy food more like clean
yes exactly and more fruits more
vegetables
i am on the diary uh diary
diary section and i think i can bring so
much
for the producers to to help them to
become more
sustainable but on the same way i have a
conflict inside
of me because um i'm not so
okay with that production so
i don't i don't know if i am strictly
what you're saying my friend
if you don't believe in what you're
supporting you will ultimately die
i i do believe that that we can we can
make a change
so then then scream about it i talk
about making a change all the time
yeah if you're if you believe you can
make a change then you need to yell
at the top of your lungs i believe that
everybody that's in this room right now
is very confused on how long life is
that's why i'm pounding in everyone's
[ __ ] face in here patience
because everybody's unhappiness comes
from thinking they haven't made it
when they haven't even [ __ ] started
so what do i do i [ __ ] pound all of
you 24 7 365
[ __ ] tick tock linkedin i'm going to
chase you all around the [ __ ]
internet
until you [ __ ] succumb into
understanding that
almost all of your unhappiness and
[ __ ] up this is predicated on you not
understanding
how long your [ __ ] life is
yeah i know i know you always talk about
how to keep things in perspective on how
to
to life life is only how you see it
i i i struggled with that because
i'm in my 34 years and
now now just i'm having some income that
allows me to
be more comfortable but i was struggling
for a lot of time
and i see all my friends you know the
typical story
of course why do you think i talk so
much about it the easiest way to be
unhappy is to compare yourself to
somebody else
and oh by the way on the record when are
you gonna compare yourself to somebody
who has a shittier
i love people like i like comparing
myself gary i'm like okay
stop comparing yourself to [ __ ]
beyonce dick
compare yourself to somebody who's got
it shittier than you
i i completely understand just just the
the
the in this pandemic situation the whole
thing about having some food to eat
having a root it's just unbelievable
somebody just died
somebody just died in the world under 40
years old
like i don't understand why people
compare themselves to the one percent of
the one percent of the one percent
once you compare yourself to all eight
billion let me promise you this
everybody who's in this room right now
there's eight billion people on earth if
you had the luxury
of having a phone an instagram account
and the ability to sign into this room
right now
you're already beating by far more than
half the world
just so you know of course
of course but nobody lives that way
nicholas everyone's crying about what
they don't have
instead of being grateful for what they
have
yes yes i know not such a powerful
message
and so by the way nicholas this is i'm
i'm answering your question right now
for the last minute
you believe in something talk about it
forever
constantly with everything from your
[ __ ]
i will i will love you guys i want to
get more people thank you thank you very
much
let me keep giving some love to so many
people in here turn on your cameras
because i want to say what's up
roy she roy what's good tyree b what's
good
johanna i love your hair what's up
diggity
what's good with that jersey i see you
charles graham i see you
savannah thanks for being here hey hey
oh you're next talking savannah that's
perfect perfect i haven't dusted on that
save wavelength let's go
dust savannah how are you yo i'm such a
huge
uh believer in energies um i'm the
founder of s3 yoga
and um honestly this would not have been
possible without i like to say i'm a
proud
student of boehner university oh
sorry my heart's beating um we're good
here we got time don't worry
functional content can we take us
actually we can definitely take our deep
breath together but i have a question
when you saw the post yes you understood
what was going on
a hundred percent so i literally just
came from a photo shoot i quit my nine
to five
i'm modeling i'm teaching yoga started
s3 yoga
like doing it i'm literally like do
literally end the [ __ ] with you
um so my my question to you right off
the bat is
i'm a yoga instructor i teach yoga for
athletes
i'll sidebar on i want to teach for
vayner sports yoga for athletes and that
stuff
but i'm at the point now where i'm
reaching out to brands d i mean
what am i asking like i'm a content
creator i'm doing the yoga
what's the best way to approach it i've
got i'm doing the dms
looking at their websites all right who
works there going to people's linkedins
all right how do i contact them
who's the person or like what would you
recommend what are you trying to get to
happen um with regards to the yoga two
things
one with s3 yoga we do private group and
online yoga sessions for athletes
um so i'm reaching out to individual
athletes but on a brand perspective
i'm a tall 511 model who does yoga i
could
i like i have brands sending me stuff
stuff like that so
uh brand partnerships and then actual
the yoga service
so i think what you need to do is
understand that just like boys hitting
on girls you can't go in for the kill on
the opening move
right and that's savannah what everybody
makes the mistake of
you're worried about on the dm or the
linkedin when you're reaching out for
business
on what you're going to get out of it so
you have to be
very thoughtful of how you bring value
you know 100 percent if i'm teaching
yoga right now
i'm offering as many free classes free
classes
i'm going live every friday good
honestly that's the only [ __ ] that
should come out of your mouth
say less that's and by the way not just
friday
right what's wrong with thursday
do it every day what am i doing i'm in
new york quarantining
you're [ __ ] quarantined if i'm you
listen you wanna know 2002 garyvee
i'm doing four yoga classes a day seven
days a week
but i'm not saying that's what you
should do
i'm just telling you to your face just
so i'm not confused here
how garyvee was built was really built
on twitter
it was seven hours a day replying to
people that didn't even know who i was
i was looking for people talking about
wine using search
and just talking to people let me say
clear for everybody in the back
seven hours a day i'm not saying people
should do that that's hard
i got crazy energy but when you're
[ __ ] hungry and you want it
like [ __ ] this one [ __ ] one and i'm
proud of you because you're doing it so
i'm not downplaying this
no 100 but if you're doing free classes
friday give me free classes seven days a
week
and then when that's give me two times a
day like [ __ ] it we're going for it out
here
right because everyone's doing
everyone's doing free everyone's doing
live it's just like it's getting
noisy i feel like but you're right but
here's the thing with noisy savannah
you're not in control of noisy
you don't get to say who goes free or
not
you know many people are pissed off that
this is happening right now because they
want to sell
mastermind courses virtually for a
thousand dollars and i'm doing it for
free right now off a [ __ ] post
and they're not even in my [ __ ] world
those people that are trying to sell
that [ __ ] they don't get to control me
we don't get to control noisy that's
called supply and demand
that call that's called being good being
better at [ __ ]
you're not paying somebody do your hair
that sucks at it
that's the fact right like so be good
and charismatic and epic on [ __ ] yoga
lives you know like let's go the queen
of good vibes that's
what that's what we're doing so let's
check this out i want you to hear this
i'm going to help a lot of people
so if you're queen of good vibes and
right like that
then you should say nothing about noisy
let's get your mind right savannah
if you're so queen vibes if you're so
good the [ __ ] you talking about noisy
for
because i'm [ __ ] insecure and like
all the [ __ ] that we talk about
yes i love you thank you for going
that's it so that's it that's what i'm
trying to talk about well good news
you can be insecure it's not good nor
bad for any of us
it's like there's really no reason to be
insecure
other than the elements that got you
there what's amazing about this moment
is
let's [ __ ] cut it out because nobody
gives a [ __ ] no one gives it everyone
has their own [ __ ]
you know what's amazing once people
realize they mean like
do you know why i'm unstoppable because
i don't think i mean
anything in the face of all the
accolades
do you know why i made this functional
post because young boy calling me out
[ __ ] blew my mind and i just needed
to flex on that [ __ ] so then i turned it
into something good
like like you know like but even in the
face of that
i still know if i walk off stage
tomorrow
people are like where did gary vee go i
get a couple seconds of love and then
every one of you [ __ ] go back to your
normal life
regardless of how much i impacted you
the second you realize
you don't mean [ __ ] is the second you
realize how happy you can become
everybody feels insecure because they
want to be somebody i'm [ __ ] the most
secure because i know i'm nobody
now comma i think i'm special
i'm trying to make november 14th a
national [ __ ] holiday out here
all right like like you know i but i
think it's a balance
of that and i think that worrying about
other people's opinions
what your mommy thinks what your daddy
thinks what your friends think
in yoga we call it non-attachment i'm so
unattached you don't even [ __ ] know
i'm complete i'm [ __ ] floating out
here
i'm right there with you but you're not
you're aspiring to be there with me yes
because when i promise you that i have
no [ __ ] idea what any other person
that kind of looks like me is doing out
there i have no [ __ ] idea
because they're winning isn't affecting
me
which then makes you a positive person
because i'm cheering for everybody out
here
i'm sure for all of y'all you think i'm
scared about people that steal my [ __ ]
and resell it i don't give a [ __ ]
you may think that's taking money out of
my pocket i don't
i don't give a [ __ ] as a matter of fact
it means i have the leverage not the
other way around
there's people making jokes about me
behind my back taking my [ __ ] and
reselling it
and i'm not selling it that make jokes i
laugh at them
i'm laughing out here savannah they're
making for
40 500 000 on my content repackaging it
selling it [ __ ] courses i don't give
a [ __ ]
right it's not taking anything out of me
and they need me i don't even know they
exist
that's like my favorite when people
don't like it when i say something
special you know
unfollowed you think that [ __ ] hurt me
you think leaving a comment saying
unfollowed because you didn't like who i
voted for or do you know like this or
that
you think that you think that hurt me
that hurt you
right that hurt you
get to that [ __ ] place savannah i
will
every day it's like some days i need to
take a week off from gary and
actually go do [ __ ] but then other weeks
it's like i need to hear it i need the
reminder i feel like it's
teaching what listening to you every day
through the podcast it's like
pair like choosing your parents right
we're i'm unlearning bad habits that
society and my parents have taught
me each and every and i need it every
day i don't need to listen anymore but i
need it every day
and you want to hear something crazy and
i listen to myself every day too i'm
talking to myself every day
it's every day every day every day all
right well
thank you so much todd
what's good alfredo's is still in the
building rory's in the building
martina good to see you i've
david great to see you well calmer
somebody's talking what's good who yes
sir yes sir
how's it going gary what's good damaris
oh you got the crew you got the full
crew in there let's go
we got the squad in there yes sir
what's up gary man look man so first
first of all i
want to say entrepreneurship practice
and um what's another good word for us
what
look man so a couple weeks ago we uh
entered the
hbcu battle of the brains competition
and we were actually the ones who asked
you that a question about if we won
we'll get the hit
could hit you up um we only came in
third place right yeah
we're not like we're not even gonna hear
them not gonna waste time
in third place
but man so uh after that we got a chance
to speak to one of your hr people or
patrick shaw
okay yeah out out in l.a yeah
yeah so we got to go ahead
we got the chance to speak to uh patrick
and you know we was
we were telling we were talking to
patrick about how excited we were to
meet him and we're telling them about
some of the things we do we literally
like
we're in the car right now because we
just came from doing a um our
our brand is all the advantage and we
just came from
uh literally that's now doing our pop-up
it's our second pop-up
the first one went so well last week
that we popped up here now
so we did it again yeah and um
we really like uh okay
okay we hit up patrick to see if there
was any opportunities that he was
telling us about creating positions
and how we would have to uh we just need
to send him our uh our websites and all
of that to do that and
and i guess i well to you right now is
as as creators gary we we content create
all day
we love entrepreneurship like literally
gary the reason why we're talking to you
right now is because we were selling we
went to the street corner
look and we're legally not supposed to
be here but we're selling our vintage
clothing
and then we saw you have this going on
so we're here and we're just wondering
is there any way we can create content
and bring that same energy to you and
you and vaynermedia what can we do gary
one of the three of you email me right
now gary intermedia
and say yo i'm one of the one one of the
guys that's part of the
three-person crew and let's talk and
i'll put it into motion
gotcha all right fellas
i got love for you guys thank you uh you
you guys are great thank you for the
love we're gonna figure something out i
gotta i got a
specific idea so damaris if it's you or
one of the other two guys just say i was
part of the
three-person squad all right what's the
email what's the email
gary vaynermedia.com all right it's
gonna come from dominique tyrell
got it i'm looking for it all right i
know you're on this look for it
justin you took care of that person spam
in the chat yeah
good move i'm impressed with your skill
set all right let's keep it going not
easy
it's it's not that hard let's not get
crazy
kale hunter what's good staphon what's
good natasha's on
natasha's on natasha what's good marcos
natasha hi
hi um
okay i was on t back a few months ago
well not a few months ago probably like
six months ago
um i at that point had like 60 000 on
tic tac and i've since
more than doubled it um i get reached
out to you by brands
all the time like non-stop i've turned
down
so many different offers um in
choosing that and kind of and like
monetizing the platform
um just like overall advice and like
choosing who would work
with and who not to work with are you
are you
not doing the brand stuff
because you don't think it's right
yeah so my tick tock is my business
i paint custom denim
kind of stuff and so like i'll get
reached out to by like a bikini company
and i'm like that doesn't make sense
and so have you been reached out to by
anybody
that does make sense
yeah a couple times but i still just say
no because you have an idea just the
idea that
yeah do you have an ideology against
brands being able to do it
like you don't think it's like yeah i
think you do why
you hate capitalism yeah i no i mean i
i don't know what it is but there's been
like maybe you feel like i
feel like you feel like a sellout
a little bit yeah well maybe you're too
much of an artist
uh-huh so don't you're saying like just
don't do it if it doesn't feel right
well i mean money sucks if it makes you
unhappy
yeah that i mean that that makes
complete sense yeah
i think so i mean there's probably like
a few like big brands that i would be
like
100 yes but so
so keep does it make it look bad
no wait a minute now you're talking now
you're talking influencer strategy are
you saying
let me get this if i'm getting it right
that you've been saying no
to smaller things because you think it's
going to [ __ ] you up from getting
patagonia
or lululemon or correct correct correct
yes you don't give a [ __ ]
okay all right so for instance i
make stickers and i got reached out to
by a water bottle company
and they were like a super small company
or whatever and
in my mind i'm like oh i'd love to work
with like hydro flask because that's the
brand that i already use and like love
so does it look bad if i've already
worked with that smaller brand
instead of like getting the bigger brand
i would probably reach out
on dm to on instagram and tick tock to
hydro flask in that situation and say
hey
i've been reached out to a lot of other
brands but you're my favorite and then i
probably do that once
every month for three months and then
after that probably move on
okay that way to me i want you to be
on the offense or and patient be on the
offense and be patient
so the two moves are either reach out to
the brands you want to work with or you
wait till you get big enough and they're
reaching out to you
both work
i think okay yeah good got it awesome
thanks good night thank you thank you
i don't want to hug her too much at your
time
what's good me and patel what's good
jayden i see you
isaiah f eating that apple all
seriousness i love that [ __ ]
trevor okay javier jay's in the building
barry eisenberg todd's got a hoodie on
orlando's got the puma rocking
oh john's got the [ __ ] leopard
[ __ ] is it hello
awesome um this is amazing i immediately
said i had goosebumps i got my daughter
in my hands
but um congratulations my question right
now
is i guess i'm considered a dreamer
amongst my friends
okay because you don't do [ __ ] my goals
are always a lot
higher and i look a lot bigger than them
but with everything with kovid
and uh how the changes in how people
move
it's how do you go about really reaching
out and getting these uh
making content with people who are
on that same level like how do you find
these people
who are basically in line with the
things that you want to get done
when it's almost uh taboo to
meet with people in person am i reaching
out
like first of all trip trey
they yeah trey the um
kobet's not forever that's true so
you know is a taboo to meet with people
yeah a lot of people don't [ __ ] want
to meet
other people do want to meet so i think
you if you're reaching out to somebody
to collab
and i'll go and i'm going to ask you a
couple more questions to figure out
what's going on but
if you're looking to do something with
somebody and they don't want to like
when you reach out to him you're like
hey you want to do something virtually
or in person let me know
that's how you ask
what do you look how you look what are
you looking to connect to do what about
what
um oddly uh my passion
is to try to start a consulting
company that deals in at-home
cannabis uh operations in a
what do you mean at home cannabis
operations so basically setting
up basically putting together everything
to set up for
uh legal card holders to grow inside of
their homes
love it understood we were consulting so
what do you who are you trying to collab
with
other thinkers to start your firm
exactly okay so you're making you know
you're making an excuse that you can't
meet in person right
that if you can ask trey can i ask you a
question do you think your friends
talk about you being a dreamer because
you talk a lot of stuff but you don't
act on it and i'm not asking you in a
negative way i want you to win
but when i hear when i hear you say your
friends think of you as a dreamer
and then as i go through the series of
my questions and i hear the way you're
thinking
and i see you're saying it's taboo to
meet in person
i'm i'm wondering if you're
creating excuses where there's no
restriction
you can do everything you need to do
virtually
i i guess really it's more more of when
i say
hey this would be a great idea
i have uh the my my small circle which
is
actually small right now it's that'll
never work that'll never work that'll
never work
and i just want to reach out to people
who are like
yeah let's get this [ __ ] going so reach
out to people
mm-hmm well i mean i appreciate i
appreciate the time and i appreciate it
real quick no no i'm not letting you go
that easy
easy when i say when i say then reach
out to people
what's making you not
um i have i mean i'm not saying how many
how many uh at this moment this is just
something that is new
probably within a month so about five
people great and nobody replied
um actually i had two to reply so far so
those are going in the right direction
but with the covet thing i haven't been
really traveling
too why don't why don't you zoom them
um i've had video conferences but i
guess i just wanted
more if that makes any sense
or putting the things in a place to get
everything off the ground
like i i hear exactly where you're
coming from and honestly just where
with the the things that you're telling
me
it almost seems as though like i'm my
own roadblock
let's just get the [ __ ] [ __ ] going
everybody's their own roadblock good
news trey you aren't alone every one of
us here are our own biggest roadblock
you know that right
yeah that's true [ __ ] you know and i
your ability to
persevere through the people around you
that that are looking to keep you
down because they have their own pain
well you have the ability to put
positivity in your ears and not listen
to that [ __ ]
exactly i find it funny that everybody
understood as high school kids
or junior high kids let me put on music
so i can hear the [ __ ] i want to hear
instead of the outside noise but then in
real life they don't realize they can do
that too
that's true you need to figure out the
allocation of what you're listening to
i appreciate that man i appreciate you
my man all right thank you for this this
is amazing
i got javier jay what's good
alexis i see you luke i see you with the
legacy over currency
photo on the back that's what's up
joshua see you
nice hair nice beard nice glasses i like
that hi hi
oh my gosh hi gary hi how are you
i'm wow um hi
um wow so
thank you so much for being you you've
you're totally like my shield like
you're just telling the other guy like
i listen to your content to create that
bubble so that i can
keep and stay focused 100
yeah um so i wanted to
i wanted to thank you because um
i'm so i'm an acupuncturist and i i got
licensed about three years ago
um i've kind of during that time i've
just been like i read your book um
i've gone through so much of your
content i did some garage sale
i um did you have anything do you have
any good flips
you know i found these um
oh man don't tell me i'm gonna lose my
words now
yu-gi-oh these yu-gi-oh tins um on ebay
that they were like
13 bucks and a piece that they were
selling on
ebay and then someone was just giving
giving away for free like a huge um
garbage bag of them for free yes they
just left on the corner so
um just the process of listing that
and like knowing the details so that
people will
buy it by like mine as opposed to the
other people who are listed on ebay
um and then i guess it's just a matter
of patience really
but yeah so i've been doing
experimenting like doing these micro
experiments
based off of things that you bring up
um but also what you've been talking
about with
patients um and having endurance for the
long haul has
it's really what's shifted my strategy
like i'm applying for a job at the local
organic market
moms just so i cuz i figured out that
in order to be able to communicate
better
i need to um actually need to like
eat more and um that's going to help me
find my community communication strategy
to do more of what you talk about like
on
on tick tock and on linkedin because you
see that's where the organic reach is
right now
um does that make sense
of course it makes sense yeah but i
think what i want to make sure is that
that's not the only place that you apply
yeah yeah i also applied
i went back to the um i worked at an
herb shop
the smile group shop in college park for
five years so i i got back in touch with
them so that i'll be able to um
see clients there once they open up yeah
i
mean
you just have to you just have to
weather the storm
yeah you just have to realize it's not
forever
yeah are you doing okay are you
struggling during this downtime
um yeah i think mostly it's
like the loneliness because you know
people
are isolated um and
you know you're not you know that you're
in control of your loneliness because
you have the ability
to go out and interact digitally you
know that right
yeah so things like this you know like i
signed up for notifications
um i've been i've been
putting myself out there more
are you are you comfortable with that or
is that hard for you
that's really hard like when you talk
about documenting and being able to like
just show up as you are
on social media you know just your
quirks people will find you
you don't have to change yourself like
i'm definitely working on
on that well good news i'm watching the
chat right now explode
with love for you like i highly highly
highly recommend
that you stay on here and connect with
some of the people i think everybody
here should put their
um you know their their
instagram username here and like
i literally think you're gonna make four
friends right now that you can talk to i
really believe that
okay yeah i'm gonna i'll do that yeah
the chat's lighting up right now you see
the chat in your screen because you
might be on an iphone you see where it
is
yeah okay good yeah make make some
friends
all right because if anybody says people
i miss that it cut off for some reason i
said if anybody's in this room right now
they're good people
yeah yeah tristan wants to smoke a fatty
tincture but yeah
awesome all right let's move on thanks
all right thank you so much karen of
course
let's keep this going allen j what's
good
careel patel see you
spencer in what's good thanks for being
in the room amir g
flavio i see you luke see you
zach's got the hair it's easy my man's
got the hair i see you bro
yo yo yo yeah who's here it's me bro
it's me to the le
i don't see him yeah so basically bro i
don't know what to say
but you're you're one of the biggest
inspirations i have
and um just wanted to ask you a question
then
i want to ask you something else i want
to ask you if you had to start over
with the knowledge you have right now
but with no resources
no money no nothing what is the first
thing
you would do i would go
work for somebody that i want to be like
for as little money as possible and live
off that money
[ __ ] well gary i've been i've talked to
david meltzer you're a good friend
yeah and i've had an interview with him
and i've been talking to your assistants
i've been talking to
vaynermedia trying to get you on my
podcast for as long
as possible bro i've been dming you
[ __ ]
25 times i've been sending out tweets
doing all that [ __ ]
uh and i just want to see bro good news
we're here
yeah yeah but i would love to get like a
deep
conv con for going with you and share
ideas
and bring value to people as you always
say so i would love
to have you on how can we make that
happen
either the serendipity of a moment like
this
or you build up leverage right like
life's about
either luck or leverage you know so for
me in this scenario it's either
you know sometimes in this exact moment
i say yes sometimes in this exact moment
i say no i'm still not sure where i'm
going
the other way to get it done is for you
to build a foundation of a meaningful
platform that makes me want to be on it
for the exposure right
for me i don't need you to make it
meaningful impact
on people in the world you need me to
bring exposure to you so that you can
build a platform and that's fine
i do that all day i do that all the time
i can't do it for
the 99.9 of people to ask me because i
get
i mean if you ever saw my dms you would
laugh like there's you know
25 times times 25 000 people times
25 000 times a day and by the way
i'm flattered by that i don't think i'm
fancy i don't think but have you
my biggest problem my man is i'm like
i'm into like
june of next year of bookings
to be on podcasts of people that i've
promised three years ago because i have
no time
right like time is my biggest [ __ ]
problem that's why i try to do
you know it's why what i think what i
just did with this today
is something i want more people to do
because the biggest thing you can give
people is time
i'm doing it broadly here you know the
the tough thing with doing the show is
time but
i'll say this i'm i'm happy to do 10
minutes
10 minutes in q1 of next year so you can
email
me right now dustin will find it you
know hit up dustin
or hit it you know or actually anybody
on my team on here dustin anybody from
the team on here if you want
just put my email in the chat for this i
think we'll lose it what's that dustin
um zane's here and zayn zane can you
take care of this
i trust you yo gary man i don't know
what to say
but uh hey thank you i respect you know
what i'm gonna say something straight up
and i know all the people in this chat
think the same thing
you're a [ __ ] inspiration you're
you're literally bringing so much
value to the world and in those dark
dark times with coven and everything
everybody going through stress
anxiety depression and you're [ __ ]
bringing out that value
that positive impact to the world with
all that negative
negativity that surrounds us that is
just [ __ ] crazy bro keep doing what
you're doing
i will i just saw i just saw today uh a
post about steve jobs how he was this
leader this big leader
but everybody they just see the final
product they don't see what he did with
his employers
but when i look at you i see that you're
trying to build that legacy
but also while putting in the empathy
while putting in
the compassion and the love for people
and that's what makes you different
and i love that bro respectfully on the
bottom of my heart
thank you so much do you want me to put
my email
zayn's gonna figure this out dustin
what's going on with saying do we know
can you on mute saying zayn you around
you alive
yeah zane is here one second because
zane's i see his
video and audio but i don't see him
acting up
i see you hop hamza i see those nikes
bro
yo wow they got you i'll i got your
information i'll hit you up this weekend
my man did you have my email uh i was
gonna find you on instagram but
basically yeah so hop up hop up on
instagram
and it's mentally gray so mentally
great and gary because i want to make
sure this connection happens
mentally gray g-r-e-y so mentally gray
m-e-n-t-a-l-l-y
yeah anyways have a good day bro you are
the best and i always had that in mind
people around me told me yo when are you
going to interview gary because i
started into interviewing all these
influential and revolutionary people
i told them one day i told them one day
and you're [ __ ] in man
don't drink don't dream too big don't
dream too big i was like just see
nah man anybody anybody that tells
somebody not to dream too big
has it completely flipped the biggest
problem in the world is people dream too
slow
a hundred percent but the the thing is i
have to ask you
what's right moran i see
what is your opinion on being realistic
a lot of people around me yo
i like realism i like realism i
i love realism i'm practical as [ __ ] out
here
yep i love practicality
the reason i never had anybody say to me
don't dream too big you know why
when i would talk about [ __ ] that didn't
look obvious when i was
when i said i buy the jets and [ __ ] like
that but i was doing [ __ ] that made them
scared to tell me not to dream too big
when i hear people get told you're
dreaming too big
i get concerned because i think they're
talking and
they're not doing [ __ ] 100 i think a lot
of people
talk more than they do and that's one
thing about our world
but what is the exp a lot of people have
expectations parents around them friends
that tell them look
stick to the realistic thing don't aim
too big what would you say to that
person
i would say that person that i'm not
listening to you because i don't want
your [ __ ] life
mom
well gary it was a pleasure bro talk to
you soon
who keeps you all the best keep doing
what you're doing bro gabrielle cruz i
see you
the deal what's good daniel okay i see
you bro jay howard thank you for coming
in
thank you you can go through these cards
like crazy what's up
hi we're all huge fans including our son
i love it what are your names my name is
peekins
my name is daniqua my name is kayson
jason what's good bro
and make sure you get this photo because
it's gonna be a badass throwback
thursday one day bro you're gonna flex
on him
yeah he he made sure that we got the
screen recorded
um so we have a podcast called in comes
the money not him not
not yet so but and we're basically
talking about here comes the value in
life so not specifically money itself
but otherwise
that can provide you value or probably
be more
valuable than money itself um and we've
been
we've been doing it for a few months now
um i think we have
like the the talent and the the um
uh i guess we're meeting our
expectations as far as like
how we want it to be in some way for
where we're at
but as far as getting getting it out to
other people we're really struggling
with that
for me i'm like a i'm like a visionary
kind of guy i'm really i'm really
creative
um i think in a few years i'm going to
be just like you or a version of you yes
um and uh my wife she is like really
good with just
executing she knows what to do she's the
op she's the operator you're the creator
exactly okay good that makes sense
that's a good team it's been working out
really well it's just now we're trying
to figure okay
we're doing all this work how do we
maximize how do we maximize it what does
maximize mean
so i guess we're having trouble figuring
out like kind of get people to listen
yeah yeah and how to get people to
engage with our content making sure it's
not
like our podcast episodes aren't too
long we do it on youtube
it has it has nothing to do with length
joe rogan's long as [ __ ]
yeah and don't use don't use length as
an excuse
so we've been using some of your
strategy where we have like videos on
youtube that's like
an hour 45 and then we'll break it up
we'll have two minute
um videos on instagram 30 second clips
on
do you know that for four and a half
years i put out ungodly amounts of
content and nobody was watching
every day four and a half years do you
know that and do all of you
know that so so i think maybe
covid messed with me a little bit
because now i'm trying to figure out
like
a good system i'm very very much
impressed by
how you're able to manage your social
media like pretty much all by yourself
and and well not really i mean now i
have a humongous [ __ ] team now i did
it all by myself for seven years so i
know it's possible
yeah the the question becomes couple
things
how much tick tock content are you
putting out
tell the truth because you know i'm
gonna punch you in the face no i don't
wanna get punched gary i'm gonna tell
the truth i'm gonna punch you verbally
because i don't do the physical [ __ ] but
i'm telling you right now bro
when i ask that question and i get that
body reaction from you you know it makes
you want to take this [ __ ] laptop and
smash your [ __ ] face with it you know
that right
i know i'll tell you why i'll tell you
why because when you want it that bad
and i'm pounding in your [ __ ] skull
for free that all the actions happening
over there there
why the [ __ ] are you two coming up with
excuses for not doing it that's what i
want to know
you're absolutely right like so i think
it's just fear it's just where
oh [ __ ] i know what it is and i know
that most people
either do well getting out of fear
through warmth
or through some straight shooting [ __ ]
i'm giving you my straight shooting [ __ ]
right now
because i know you're warping each other
and it's not [ __ ] working
yeah i think for me like outside of fear
is just
like a feeling of of of overwhelmness
when i think about all of the different
options that's because you're
out here saying that you're going to be
the next me that's why you're
overwhelmed
i'm thinking too big yes bro
[Music]
the reason you're overwhelmed is you're
telling me to my face you're the next me
and you haven't gotten out of the gate
yet and that's crippling you
that doesn't mean you shouldn't have big
ambitions but if you're overthinking
your ambitions are crippling you because
i'm always thinking okay well if i'm
gonna
spend an hour i need to do the best to
maximize that hour
and then i'm looking at so many
different options until the hours of the
hour already passed
um trying to figure out what to do next
so i think i think like
pre co not too late raoul on tick tock
it just started
what are your thoughts on um what are
good options for
linkedin podcasts linkedin and tick tock
is free organic reach where the [ __ ] are
you
all at i've been telling you this [ __ ]
for 18 months you have and i'm wondering
i'm talking
i'm not talking about just youtube i'm
looking at all the faces in here that
have ambitions that want [ __ ] to happen
that are trying to get it out here
the [ __ ] are you doing in the zoom right
now what about we're watching netflix
you can be playing ps5 you could be
listening to some music
you're [ __ ] in here because you want
something yeah
and i'm telling you the free [ __ ] i'm
not even charging you for this and i'm
telling you your [ __ ] face
tick-tock linkedin tick-tock linkedin
tic-tac-toe you got a [ __ ]
podcast yeah i'm asking everybody in
here
why the [ __ ] aren't you executing on
what i'm telling you
the answer is because you're insecure
the answer is because you're insecure
the answer is because you don't fully
believe me the answer is a million
[ __ ] other things
but it's all right in your [ __ ] dome
and i don't know how to get the [ __ ] out
of you
but i'm trying a million different ways
i'll go sweet i'll go different i'll go
like this rant right now
cause one of you [ __ ] might do it
because this is the moment
i'm doing secret content i [ __ ] made
a secret zoom for you [ __ ] tonight
here we are i don't need to be doing
this [ __ ]
i'm dying out here for you guys i mean
it i want it for you real bad
you know why not because i'm [ __ ]
mother teresa
not because i'm on some altruistic [ __ ]
because it's real
it's real as [ __ ] but i can't help you
if you don't
fix the [ __ ] well which is your
[ __ ] dome
and if you don't do the [ __ ] i tell you
that's true
tick tock linkedin you know why because
when you post on those platforms
more people than you deserve will see it
you know it will go away i lived it i
lived it on twitter
i lived it on facebook lived it on
instagram you can't do that [ __ ] on
instagram now
so here here's here's what i'm getting
i'm i'm aiming a little bit high and i
think that's probably what's
helping me what's getting me overwhelmed
so i get that
um so if
i think if we say because right now we
don't even have a thousand like
subscribers on youtube or anything like
that
we have less than a thousand um
followers on on instagram
i'm thinking by the time that like let's
say
you have an opening of 10 minutes next
year on
in june of 2020 or something like that
we want to get there we want to get to
that point
um
yourselves the [ __ ] does that mean bro
the [ __ ] does a thousand mean i think i
think what's wrong with why
why why wasn't 500 good enough why isn't
5 000 good enough
bro you're making fake goals
the [ __ ] will that mean what happens
when you hit a thousand i'll get you a
thousand right now what's your [ __ ]
youtube
ad in comes the money spell that [ __ ]
i-n-c-o-m hold on
hold on hold on hold on one second
twitter.com let's see if i feel
different you're not gonna feel
different bro you're gonna feel the same
[ __ ] you feel right now
how is it spelled in in comes the money
i n c o m e s i see you you guys are
very cute good thumbnails i'm impressed
all right i'm subscribing you have now
you have 143 subscribers
now you have 144 now i'm going here
please if i've ever
done anything for you
i appreciate the gary you're gonna
appreciate the next part more
anything for you please follow this
lovely couple
aka subscribe
i'm seeing notifications that's only
coming from the people in here i haven't
even posted yet
i'm trying to teach
i'm impressed by how you execute for
real that's all i [ __ ] do bro
i think all i do is talk all i do is
[ __ ] make [ __ ] happen listen to me
man you're about to have a you're about
here you go everybody here's the [ __ ]
link click it everybody [ __ ]
all of us follow they're very lovely
it'll be fun here it is there's a lick
i really mean it i really [ __ ] truly
[ __ ] expect
all of you to follow it right now for
real for real for real
but here's the real question my man
you're not gonna feel
any different at a thousand
i think i've developed like an internal
like
expectation stop right there
and that is the end of the game for you
[ __ ] expectations focus on process do
you love doing the show
i love the process good i feel like
we're teaching ourselves stuff and then
like we review it and
we're like oh man that's that's so cool
good and then
you love the process yet you have
anxiety and tension and unhappiness
around the whole thing
because of expectations bro that is so
true we've actually said that on the
project
on the podcast and i'm a big victim of
it so
like i'm i'm trying to i'm so i think
along with the process part of what
gives me anxiety
is my lack of like execution and i've
always been curious about
what your routine is my routine is my
routine is i was blessed
my routine was i was blessed with
operational capabilities
and then i honed them since i was five
years old and now i'm 45.
talent just like you were blessed with
good looks bro
look at that compliment yeah the little
man like that [ __ ]
let's go you know listen listen to me
listen to me
you are not an operator i'm not
good news you don't need to be she is
good so stop worrying about operating
start worrying about
community and content you're not in your
community enough you
my man and that's creating more anxiety
for me
you know i don't know if anyone else can
relate it's gotten worse during covet i
think because my routine
has just hit a big bro kovid exposed
things
it didn't create things i i
you're producing a really nice youtube
show i like it i'm really like
you're putting it in like it's a nice
looking thing like you guys are doing it
but you don't understand right now is
that
the world works on everything you do
after the show not the show
i put out garbage lighting content i put
out
garbage production unless my team does
some big shout out to abby for
yesterday's post i was fired
but i'm out here putting out volume and
message
you're you're putting all your energy i
can see it from a mile away
you two are putting all your energy into
the production of the show
not the awareness of the show yeah
yeah we wanted it to we wanted it to be
something that we loved
good well then if if you wanted it to be
that then stop talking all the other
[ __ ]
because now you love it you're good you
won but that's not what you want that's
the [ __ ] coming out of your mouth
yeah yeah i want both
yeah i think i think because the
expectations of everyone else kind of
drives it
and it also messes with my anxiety
because i know i love it i know it's
great content and i wouldn't like
expectations
what other what others who know myself
like since i was young i would like i
would
i had this personality where i just feel
the need to achieve
and even if it's not up to your
expectations if i feel like i've done
like everything that i can so that by
the time i'm dead
um like i've been used as much as i
possibly can
used i feel like i'm misused or
underused
if no one even sees the effort that
we've put into something
no no bro that's you tried now that's
wrong you have it reversed
[Music]
please of course everything you just
said was about you
everything that you just said was
selfish it was yeah
you're right it was kind of selfish no
one here cares
specifically about what i'm trying to do
you know
how you feeling it's not even that
it's that you want them to look up to
you
that is true i want them to be like oh
he's the man he's good
i know what you want what he just said
was gone
you're right which is why it's not
happening
that's right it's the reverse my guy
so like so for you ready for this you
ready for this
i'm ready i don't give a [ __ ]
that everybody here thinks i'm the guy
you are though by the way but because i
care about
knowing that i have so much to give and
just giving and letting the chips fall
and whether i'm the guy or not the guy
my team will tell you i have no [ __ ]
idea i i posted the other day in our
thread that i was pumped
that my idea of my three cups post was
the worst post we've ever had
now one could sit here and say yeah but
you've got you've got
easy now no that's who i was always
bro either you're doing it out here for
them or you're doing it out here for you
right now you're doing it solely for you
so what motivates you to continue even
with
even when the results of because you you
have to have like certain things
because because because i because i like
when there's no results
i i believe i deserve them i believe you
two deserve
not having subscribers
[Music]
so we could learn from it of course
we've learned from it bro the mark the
market's always
right yeah we did just get started too
you didn't but but stick with me it's
not about that because that goes again
in excuse land
like and it's not about winning or not
winning let him do his thing i love it
listen to me it's not about you just
started it's not about how many views
you have or you're not
it's you understanding that you have to
do content that's good for them
and if you don't have subscribers
they're right not
you yeah and my intuition is that you're
like why aren't they seeing it yet
that is true because i feel like some of
this stuff marketing-wise is formulaic
in a way
where if you put the right keyword you
do x y and z you should be able to get a
little bit more than if you did none of
that
whether you have good content or not and
so i feel like once you've done all the
work
you're thinking you're thinking first of
all you haven't done it well enough
because it would have worked it's just
math but i promise you
the problem is listen to how you're
thinking let me break this down for
everybody let me break down your psyche
because this is fanta
this will help i think so first first
you're about you
you want the admiration the fame you're
worried about it from your perspective
this is all i'm hearing then
the next thing you're worried about is
hacking youtube for you
first i want it i want to win we're
going to win
we're going to be the [ __ ] we're
going to be that cute black couple we're
gonna [ __ ] win the world's gonna love
us this is our time
then then all your energy is let's let's
either
buy some [ __ ] youtube hacking course
or find some free content
and we figured out how to meta tag or
thumbnail why the [ __ ] isn't it
happening none of this has been about
doing [ __ ] for people that will bring
them tons of value
yep all right my time's up here i will
do this again
i appreciate it i love all of you i hope
everybody has a great night a good
evening all that [ __ ] i love everybody
have a great night thank you for being a
part of this everyone take care
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you